This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一个iHeart播客。百分之二。有扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人数比例是百分之二。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析我们这个奇怪的现代世界中展现出的心理坚韧、体能以及构建心理韧性的迹象。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在经历之后成为一个更快乐、更满足、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即Apple Podcasts、iHeartRadio应用或您获取播客的任何地方的“2%”。在《Look Back at it》播客中。从1979年开始，对我来说那是一个重大的时刻。84年对我来说意义重大。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利什。每集节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过那段岁月的。我们的嘉宾包括朋友、同为喜剧演员的同行以及最喜爱的作家。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代。1984年是疯狂的一年。那是疯狂的一年。我认为对黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen and learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast.
在iHeartRadio应用、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听Look Back at It。嘿，各位最近怎么样？欢迎收听《以防万一》或《学得艰难》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖恩斯。这个空间专注于黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都极其不安全、却不得不进行的坦诚对话，而你的对话对象是一位深谙此道的持证专业人士。有多少男人穿着一套盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这个能力，并不意味着你就必须这么做。在iHeartRadio应用、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听并了解《学得艰难》。
In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian. Michael Mancini.
2023年，“钻石单身汉”明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的生父。但这次怀孕似乎是一场骗局。欧文斯女士，你伪造了这份特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格，一个同性恋。迈克尔·曼奇尼。
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the podcast. the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what
我的脑子炸裂了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《爱情陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。在iHeartRadio应用、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。大家好，欢迎回到《你二十多岁的心理学》，在这个播客中，我们将探讨一些生活中的重大改变和转变。我们二十多岁时的转变以及什么
they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, you know the deal, wherever you are in the world. It is great to have you here back for another episode because this week we are going to tackle the big, scary, beast that is self-sabotage. Our 20s are such a unique time of growth and goal setting and huge moments, but it can also be very easy for us to get in our own way. I think sometimes we can be our biggest enemy because of our tendency to engage in behavior that actually undermines us and we consistently sabotage our efforts in ways that are sometimes not even obvious.
它们对我们的心理意味着什么。大家好。欢迎回到节目中。欢迎回到播客。新听众，老听众，你们都懂的，无论你们身在世界何处。很高兴能邀请你们回来收听另一期节目，因为本周我们将要攻克一个巨大、可怕且名为自我破坏的怪兽。我们二十多岁是一个非常独特的时期，充满了成长、设定目标和重大时刻，但我们也极容易作茧自缚。我认为有时我们自己就是自己最大的敌人，因为我们倾向于从事实际上会削弱我们的行为，并且我们不断地以有时甚至并不明显的方式破坏我们的努力。
So why do we do that? Why do we find ourselves acting in a manner that is contradictory to our goals and which leaves us worse off? I think a deeper question as well is why can't we let ourselves be happy and let ourselves succeed. Well, that's what we're going to explore today. I think self-sabotage comes in many forms from procrastination to impulse buying indecision, poor dating choices, starting conflict, overworking, isolating ourselves, and even more serious habits like substance abuse. But at their very core, all of these behaviours stem from the negative beliefs we hold about ourselves.
那么，我们为什么要这么做呢？为什么我们会发现自己做出的行为与目标背道而驰，反而让自己处境更糟？我认为一个更深层次的问题是，为什么我们不能让自己快乐，让自己成功。好吧，这就是我们今天要探讨的。我认为自我破坏有多种形式，从拖延、冲动购物、优柔寡断、糟糕的约会选择、挑起冲突、过度工作、自我孤立，到更严重的习惯，如药物滥用。但其核心而言，所有这些行为都源于我们对自己的负面信念。
and feeling like we don't deserve the good things in life. So choosing to sabotage ourselves before they even occur. And it was Freud who actually was one of the first people to identify these behaviors. And he believed that it derived from our unconscious beliefs and what he called the death drive, whereby all humans innately want to be free of responsibility and expectation. so they sabotage their efforts at success. For example, scrolling on TikTok rather than doing your assignment as a way of ignoring your responsibilities.
并且觉得自己不配拥有生活中的美好事物。所以在它们发生之前就选择自我破坏。弗洛伊德实际上是较早识别这些行为的人之一。他认为这源于我们的无意识信念以及他所谓的死本能，即所有人类都天生希望摆脱责任和期望。因此，他们破坏了自己走向成功的努力。例如，刷TikTok而不是完成作业，以此来逃避责任。
And psychology has obviously evolved a lot since then and now we tend to think of self-sabotage as linked to ideas around coping mechanisms, unconscious negative beliefs, self-punishment, fear of success and so much more. And I think all of those aspects of our unconscious thinking and of our self-esteem and self-concept are also the things we tend to start diving into and digging into and uncovering in our 20s. So they are inextricably linked. I also want to talk about the many innocent-looking behaviours that are encouraged by society but are actually a form of self-sabotage and why it is so hard to identify.
从那以后，心理学显然发生了很大的变化，现在我们倾向于将自我破坏与应对机制、无意识的消极信念、自我惩罚、对成功的恐惧等等概念联系起来。而且我认为我们无意识思维的所有这些方面，以及我们的自尊和自我概念，也是我们在二十多岁时开始深入探究、挖掘和揭示的东西。所以它们有着千丝万缕的联系。我还想谈谈许多看似无辜、受到社会鼓励但实际上是一种自我破坏的行为，以及为什么识别它们如此困难。
when we are deliberately handicapping ourselves and getting out of our own way. So in this episode, we are going to dive into the fascinating psychology behind self-sabotage from the origins and the causes of self-destructive behaviours to the major signs that you are a self-saboture, the obvious and the less obvious, why we self-sabotage the links to childhood, to trauma, but also ultimately how we can cultivate healthier habits and patterns and let go of our negative beliefs to break the cycle of self-sabotage. So if you are sick of striking yourself down and being your own worst enemy, this episode is for you. I cannot wait to get into it. So without further ado, let's go.
当我们刻意阻碍自己并摆脱自己的阻碍时。所以在这期节目中，我们将深入探讨自我破坏背后迷人的心理学，从自我毁灭行为的根源和原因，到你是自我破坏者的主要明显和不太明显的迹象，我们为什么要自我破坏，这些与童年、创伤的联系，但最终也是我们如何培养更健康的习惯和模式，放下消极信念，打破自我破坏的循环。所以，如果你厌倦了打击自己并成为自己最糟糕的敌人，这期节目就是为你准备的。我已经迫不及待要开始了。废话不多说，我们开始吧。
self-sabotage, also known as self-destructive behaviour, is a pattern of habits and actions and unconscious decisions that are innately harmful, and they undermine our goals and well-being, or just all-around levels of happiness. At their core, these behaviours are driven by things like unresolved emotional pain, low self-esteem, a sense of unworthiness, and the sense that we need to almost punish ourselves for something that's happened in the past. Individuals who engage in these self-destructive behaviours, probably like you and I, they may use them as coping mechanisms to numb or distract themselves from their underlying psychological distress. It obviously differs from what we would typically see as sabotage, like in the movies
自我破坏，也被称为自我毁灭行为，是一种本质上有害的习惯、行动和无意识决策的模式，它们会削弱我们的目标和幸福感，或者削弱我们的整体幸福水平。在其核心，这些行为是由未解决的情感痛苦、低自尊、不配感以及几乎觉得我们需要为过去发生的事情惩罚自己的感觉等因素驱动的。进行这些自我毁灭行为的个人，可能就像你和我一样，他们可能会将其作为应对机制，来麻木自己或转移注意力，以摆脱潜在的心理困扰。这显然不同于我们通常在电影中看到的破坏
or in like a Shakespeare play, you know, the form of malicious actions by others to disrupt or hinder us. And it really zones in on this idea and belief that we can be our own biggest saboteur when it comes to not just our major goals, but also our everyday life. And I think secret here is that everyone engages in these kinds of behaviours. Every single one of us will self-sabotage at some point in our lives. And when we are in our 20s, I think we are particularly vulnerable because we don't yet have a strong identity. We can be super confused about our goals and our future. And we don't really yet have as much of that hindsight or experience to recognize the correlation between certain habits and the outcomes that cause us to stress and cause us to undermine our
或者像莎士比亚戏剧中那样，你知道，这是他人采取的破坏或阻碍我们的恶毒行为。它真正聚焦于这样一种观念和信念，即在不仅关乎我们主要目标、也关乎我们日常生活的时候，我们自己就是最大的破坏者。我认为这里的秘诀在于，每个人都会从事这类行为。我们当中的每一个人，在生活中的某个时刻都会进行自我破坏。当我们二十多岁时，我认为我们尤其脆弱，因为我们还没有建立起强大的认同感。我们可能会对自己的目标和未来感到非常困惑。而且我们还没有足够的这种事后诸葛亮的智慧或经验来识别某些习惯与导致我们压力并导致我们破坏进度的结果之间的相关性
progress or just our life in general. The origins of this term or idea that actually they're somewhat ancient. It is this idea that has been around for some time and used it in one way or another to describe individuals who acted in a quote unquote unsavory manner. But it wasn't really given a formal name or really studied until the late 1800s. And who do we have to think for that? Well, of course, it was Freud, the granddaddy of psychology. Self-sabotage has a lot to do with our ego and our unconscious beliefs and our childhood development.
进展，或者只是我们的整体生活。这个词或想法的起源其实有些古老。这个概念已经存在了一段时间，并以这样或那样的方式被用来描述那些以“引号中的”令人讨厌的方式行事的个人。但直到19世纪后期，它才被赋予正式名称或真正进行研究。我们要感谢谁呢？当然是弗洛伊德，心理学的老祖宗。自我破坏与我们的自我、我们的无意识信念以及我们的童年发展息息相关。
So, of course, Freud is going to have his fingers in this in some form or another. And he was the one who came up with and kind of presented. this idea of the death drive, which he believed was innate in humans, and it is essentially this unconscious psychological urge towards self-destruction, which he theorized was actually really cathartic. You know, ruining your life meant being free from ordinary stresses and responsibilities and kind of claiming a whole new set of burdens, but for just a second, we feel really liberated. And he was describing what we now know as self-destructive behaviors or self-sabotage. And they can really occur in any domain of life, you know, our relationships, our careers,
所以，弗洛伊德当然会以某种形式插手其中。正是他提出了并展示了这一观点。这种死亡驱力的概念，他认为这是人类天生具有的，它本质上是一种走向自我毁灭的无意识心理冲动，他从理论上讲这其实非常具有宣泄作用。你知道，毁掉你的生活意味着从日常压力和责任中解放出来，并承担一套全新的负担，但仅仅有一秒钟，我们感觉真的解放了。他所描述的就是我们现在所知的自我毁灭行为或自我破坏。它们确实可以发生在生活的任何领域，你知道，我们的关系、我们的职业生涯、
our family, our physical well-being, emotional well-being, or just general happiness, you know, where there is room to grow or succeed, there is room to self-sabotage. I know I've already given some examples, but I want to give some more here just to paint kind of a broader image of what this looks like. It may be, you know, starting fights with your partner even when you're not mad, lashing out, you know, neglecting your physical needs, being unconsciously indecisive, ignoring your intuition, maybe making dating choices you know you shouldn't be doing or scrolling on your phone or impulse buying. Anything that actually is counterproductive to a conscious goal you have,
我们的家庭、我们的身体健康、情感健康或纯粹的总体幸福感，你知道，只要有成长或成功的空间，就有自我破坏的空间。我知道我已经给出了一些例子，但我在这里想给出更多例子，以便更广泛地描绘出这到底是什么样子。这可能是，你知道，即使你不生气也和伴侣挑起争端，大发雷霆，你知道，忽视你的生理需求，无意识地优柔寡断，忽视你的直觉，也许做出你明知不该做的约会选择，或者刷手机或冲动购物。任何实际上与你心中的意识目标背道而驰的事情，
but you physically cannot stop yourself from doing. It's like this strange kind of alter ego has taken over your body and is making you act in a certain way. That is a self-sabotaging behavior. and the reason why I stress this almost inability to stop ourselves is because these behaviors can be conscious or unconscious. And this kind of depends on our level of self-awareness or I guess denial. This links back to Freud's initial ideas and conceptualization of self-sabotage, whereby he believed that the reason we create obstacles for ourselves is because we're our subconscious mind, also known as the anti-self, interrupts our logical conscious mind,
但你身体上就是无法停止自己不去这么做。这就好像某种奇怪的另一个人格接管了你的身体，让你做出某种特定的行为。这就是自我破坏行为。我之所以强调这种几乎无法制止自己的能力，是因为这些行为可以是有意识的，也可以是无意识的。这在一定程度上取决于我们的自我觉察水平，或者说我的否认程度。这可以追溯到弗洛伊德关于自我破坏的最初想法和概念化，他认为我们为自己制造障碍的原因是我们的潜意识，也被称为反我，打断了我们合乎逻辑的意识思维，
making them at conflict. For example, you may be wanting to treat your body better and eat healthier and be more active, but you find yourself inexplicably always missing your workouts or eating foods, you know what make you feel good, drinking juice and soft drink instead of water. And in those instance, it's because your logical conscious mind, which is responsible for goal-driven behavior, is being undermined by this anti-self. And this anti-self, this unconscious impulse may stem from us just kind of not believing that we deserve the future we're striving for or that we deserve to live in a gentle, non-caotic environment.
使它们发生冲突。例如，你可能想要更好地对待自己的身体，吃得更健康，更积极地运动，但你却发现自己莫名其妙地总是错过锻炼，或者吃那些你知道会让你感觉不好的食物，喝果汁和软饮料而不是水。在那些情况下，这是因为你的负责目标驱动行为的逻辑意识思维正被这个反我所削弱。而这个反我、这种无意识的冲动可能源于我们内心某种程度上不相信自己配得上我们正在努力争取的未来，或者我们不配生活在一个温和、不混乱的环境中。
and that's one of the deeper, I guess, root issues and causes of self-sabotage, our internal belief system around what we feel we deserve in life. And these notions of self-punishment and a distorted sense of self-worth. I think that's why it's so maladaptive. And another reason we find it difficult to recognize self-destructive patterns is not just because they are unconscious, but because sometimes they are so deeply ingrained and part of the fabric of society
这也是自我破坏的更深层根源和原因之一，即我们关于自己在生活中配得上什么东西的内部信念系统。以及这种自我惩罚的概念和扭曲的自我价值感。我认为这就是为什么它如此适应不良。我们发现自己难以识别自我毁灭模式的另一个原因，不仅仅是因为它们是无意识的，还因为有时它们根深蒂固，甚至是社会结构的一部分，
that we don't even blink an eye or take time to examine what they mean for us on an individual level. Something I've realized is that there are so many insidious, sometimes invisible behaviors, that are actually really self-destructive. And some of them are socially acceptable and encouraged, so we may not always think about them. I think of habits like overworking or excessive busyness.
以至于我们甚至都不会眨一下眼睛，也不会花时间去审视它们对我们的个人层面意味着什么。我意识到的一点是，有许多潜滋暗长、有时甚至看不见的行为，实际上确实具有自我破坏性。其中一些是社会所接受和鼓励的，所以我们可能不会总是去思考它们。我想到了过度工作或过度忙碌之类的习惯。
But the biggest one I've been considering a lot recently is drinking alcohol. I drink alcohol. I love a fun night. I love a cheeky cocktail, a celebratory drink or two. But I think recently I've become very sober curious, I would say. And I saw this post the other day that really, solidified this thinking for me. And what it said was this. Alcohol is the only drug that causes intergenerational trauma that is still socially celebrated and accepted. Alcohol is a drug. We often do
但我最近一直在思考的最大一个问题是喝酒。我喝酒。我喜欢有趣的夜晚。我喜欢一杯时髦的鸡尾酒，或者一两杯庆祝的酒。但我认为最近我对清醒充满了好气，可以说。我几天前看到了这样一篇文章，它真的巩固了我的这种想法。文章是这样说的。酒精是唯一一种会导致代际创伤却仍然受到社会庆祝和接受的毒品。酒精是一种毒品。我们经常
not think about it on the same level as something like cocaine or meth, but it is addictive. It impacts our behavior. It works on our body in a depressive way, much like things like Valium or a benzodiazepine and I think it is the best example of a socially acceptable behaviour that actually contains an element of self-sabotage and obviously it exists on a spectrum ranging from you know straight up alcoholism to just consuming excessive alcohol in a way that is actually inconsistent with our values or plans you know being hung over for work or drinking before you know you have a big day or that you want to go for a run. But society doesn't really seem to have a problem with that. It doesn't have a problem with being drunk or hung over or using
不会把它和诸如可卡因或冰毒之类的东西相提并论，但它是会让人上瘾的。它会影响我们的行为。它以类似于安定或苯二氮䓬类药物的方式对我们的身体产生抑郁作用，我认为这是社会可接受行为的最佳例子，这种行为实际上包含了一定程度的自我破坏，而且显然它存在于一个光谱上，从纯粹的酗酒到仅仅是过度饮酒，而这种饮酒实际上与我们的价值观或计划不符，你知道，宿醉去上班，或者在你明知有一整天要忙或者想去跑步之前喝酒。但社会似乎对此并没有什么意见。对于喝醉、宿醉，或者利用
alcohol to celebrate or even subconsciously numb some internal conflict we're having until it crosses over into an area that is socially unacceptable. And I really think that line is not all too clear. think the consumption of alcohol is a really good example to use here because it highlights A, how self-sabotaging is socially acceptable, but B, how these behaviors are also in some ways coping mechanisms. So coping mechanisms in psychology are these psychological and behavioral responses that we use to manage stress and emotions or challenging situations. And they can be maladaptive, meaning not appropriate for the situation we're in unhealthy, or they can be adaptive. So let's view them in the context of self-sabotage in which the coping mechanisms we employ
酒精来庆祝，甚至下意识地麻痹我们正在经历的某种内心冲突，社会并不会觉得有什么问题，直到它越界进入了社会不可接受的领域。我真的认为那条界限并不是十分清晰。我认为酒精的消耗是一个非常好的例子，因为它突出了A，自我破坏是如何被社会所接受的，但B，这些行为在某些方面也是应对机制。因此，心理学中的应对机制是我们用来管理压力、情绪或具有挑战性的情况的心理和行为反应。它们可能是适应不良的，意味着不适合我们所处的、不健康的处境，或者它们可能是适应性的。因此，让我们在自我破坏的背景下来看待它们，在这个背景下，我们采用的应对机制
are going to be maladaptive because they are contrary to our conscious goals. For example, when we feel stressed, we use alcohol to calm us down, or when we are depressed, we isolate, when we are facing a major work or study deadline, we doomscroll on social media, we distract ourselves. All of these things may feel initially pleasant and useful, but in the long run, they are actually highly detrimental
将是适应不良的，因为它们与我们的意识目标背道而驰。例如，当我们感到压力时，我们用酒精来让自己平静下来，或者当我们抑郁时，我们选择孤立自己，当我们面临重大工作或学习死线时，我们在社交媒体上无休止地刷屏，我们转移注意力。所有这些事情刚开始时可能会感觉很愉快、很有用，但从长远来看，它们实际上极其有害，
and they will leave us feeling worse off. And a lot of the research into self-destructive behaviors demonstrates that link to unhealthy coping mechanisms. But I want to talk now about some of the signs that you are a self-saboture, that you are your own worst enemy, as we say. Recognizing signs of self-sabotage is, of course, I think, an important step in addressing and overcoming these self-defeating behaviours. We've talked a lot about why it is that they're negative and some of the early and more current and modern theories around why they exist.
并且会让我们感觉处境更糟。许多关于自我毁灭行为的研究都证明了它与不健康应对机制之间的联系。但现在我想谈谈你是自我破坏者的某些迹象，也就是我们常说的，你成为了自己最大的敌人。识别自我破坏的迹象，当然，我认为这是解决和克服这些自虐行为的重要一步。我们已经讨论了很多为什么它们是消极的，以及围绕它们为什么存在的一些早期、最新和现代的理论。
But what do we need to look out for if you think that you are someone who self-saboture? sabotages. Number one, if you always blame others and choose to ignore how your behavior correlates to an outcome, this demonstrates a lack of self-awareness around the decisions we make and how they contribute to our overall happiness and satisfaction in life. It is very easy to bury our head in the sand when we feel trapped in a cycle of bad decisions and subsequent consequences, but the truth is that you are really the captain of your own ship and blaming others is just a massive indicator that you may actually be self-sabotaging because it is a lot easier to attribute our faults and our mistakes to others than to ourselves. And it's all in an
但是，如果你觉得自己是一个会自我破坏的人，我们需要注意什么呢？第一点，如果你总是责怪他人，并选择忽视你的行为与结果之间的相关性，这表明我们对自己所做决策缺乏自我觉察，也不清楚它们如何促成了我们在生活中的整体幸福感和满意度。当我们觉得自己陷入了一系列糟糕决定及随之而来的后果的循环中时，我们很容易把头埋在沙子里，但事实是，你真的是自己命运的船长，而责怪他人正是一个巨大的指标，表明你可能实际上在自我破坏，因为把我们的过失和错误归咎于他人，要比归咎于自己容易得多。这一切都是为了
effort to protect our self-esteem. It's also known in psychology as attribution theory. So according to this theory, we often attribute the causes of events and outcomes to other people in a way that we externalize the cause and we externalize the problem to protect our self-image. And that is self-destructive because it denies us agency over our lives. It's called this idea of an external locus of control. We've spoken about it on the show before. essentially what it comes down to attribution theory, externalizing our problems, blaming others, is that we never feel like we are actually responsible for our lives.
努力保护我们的自尊。在心理学中，这也称为归因理论。根据这一理论，我们经常将事件和结果的原因归咎于其他人，以此来外化原因和问题，从而保护我们的自我形象。这是自我毁灭性的，因为它剥夺了我们对生活的掌控权。这被称为外部控制源的概念。我们以前在节目中讨论过它。归因理论、外化我们的问题、责怪他人的核心本质在于，我们从不觉得我们实际上对自己的生活负有责任。
And that makes it easy to feel like the bad things are not our fault, but also that the good things are all due to luck. And it's part of the self-sabotaging kind of cycle because we can be acting in a way that is entirely unhelpful and entirely unuseful and contradictory to our goals, but as long as we see it as someone else's problem, we are never going to change. The second biggest sign I would say is choosing to walk away when things get hard.
这使得我们很容易觉得坏事不是我们的错，但也觉得好事全凭运气。这是自我破坏循环的一部分，因为我们的行为可能完全无益、毫无用处，并且与我们的目标背道而驰，但只要我们把这看作是别人的问题，我们就永远不会改变。我要说的第二个最大迹象是，当事情变得艰难时，选择一走了之。
This demonstrates that you may unconsciously not believe that your goals are worth sacrifice and consequently that you are not worth the sacrifice, choosing to stick it out when things get tough shows a commitment to your growth you know as we always say on this podcast you can either be comfortable or you can choose to grow and when we shy away from the nitty-gritty of life we are essentially self-sabotaging and this can be explained by two psychological phenomena firstly learned helplessness and secondly a fear of failure this idea of learned helplessness was developed by Martin Seligman, and he came to the idea after he witnessed dogs essentially
这表明你可能在潜意识里认为你的目标不值得你做出牺牲，因此你也不值得为此做出牺牲。在事情变得艰难时选择坚持到底，表明了你对自身成长的承诺，你知道，正如我们在这个播客中经常说的那样，你可以选择安逸，也可以选择成长，当我们对生活中的繁文缛节避之不及的时候，我们本质上就是在自我破坏，这可以由两种心理现象来解释：首先是习得性无助，其次是对失败的恐惧。这种习得性无助的概念是由马丁·塞利格曼提出的，他在亲眼目睹了狗基本上被
being tied up and sadly abused. And what he found was that these dogs would continue to withstand that abuse even when they were released and they could run away or escape. And he drew from that conclusion and he linked it to the behavior he was observing in humans. And this idea of learned helplessness theory, it suggests that certain people may develop a belief that their actions have no influence or control over challenging situations. When we repeatedly encounter difficult or stressful circumstances, we do not see a positive outcome as possible. They learn to feel helpless. We learn to disengage from these situations as a coping mechanism. And it is a huge sign that you are at the end of the day in a cycle of self-sabotaging and unconsciously,
捆绑起来并悲惨地虐待之后想出了这个想法。他发现，即使在这些狗被释放、可以逃跑或逃脱时，它们仍然会继续承受这种虐待。他从这个结论中得出推论，并把它与他在人类身上观察到的行为联系起来。这种习得性无助理论表明，某些人可能会产生一种信念，认为他们的行动对具有挑战性的情况没有任何影响或控制力。当我们反复遇到困难或压力的环境时，我们认为不会有积极的结果。他们学会了感到无助。我们学会了从这些情境中抽离出来作为一种应对机制。这是一个巨大的信号，表明你归根结底正处于自我破坏的循环中，并且在潜意识里，
you do not believe that you are worth the effort. You do not believe that you are worth the hard times and so you kind of just walk away when things get tough. The third indicator is creating problems and conflict in your relationships. This is something that I've had to identify and unlearn in my own life. In a lot of my past relationships, I found that when things got really good, when I felt really secure, there was this part of me that almost felt uncomfortable with the level of peace and security that I was experiencing. You know, I know how to operate when things are hard. I know how to operate when things are rocky. And I think I find myself inherently more prepared for those worst case scenarios, so that is where I feel safe. And what that means is that when things are going
你不相信自己值得付出努力。你不相信自己值得经历艰难时光，所以当事情变难时，你就会一走了之。第三个指标是在你的关系中制造问题和冲突。这是我在自己的生活中不得不去识别并改掉的问题。在我过去的很多感情中，我发现当一切变得很好时，当我感到非常安全时，我内心深处总有那么一部分，对所经历的那种平静和安全感感到有些不舒服。你知道，当事情变得艰难时，我知道该如何应对。当事情动荡不安时，我知道该如何应对。我想我发现自己天生对那些最坏的情况更有准备，所以那就是我感到安全的地方。这意味着当事情进展顺利时
really well in my relationships, it's almost like I don't know how to be happy. So I would start fights. I would find something small and I would make it big. And I really don't feel ashamed to admit that because it's definitely something I've worked through and I know it's actually fairly common, but it's also not frequently discussed. And that habit, both in our roommates, relationships and also amongst family members, amongst colleagues, amongst friends, it's often due to self-destructive tendencies and things like insecurity, a fear of intimacy, unresolved emotional issues and difficulties with control, all of which are at the root of self-sabotaging. Equally, if you keep finding yourself in relationships with the same kinds of people,
在我的关系中，这几乎就像我不知道该如何快乐。所以我会挑起争端。我会找一件小事，然后把它放大。我并不为此感到羞耻，因为这确实是我一直在努力克服的事情，而且我知道这其实挺普遍的，但它也并不常被讨论。这种习惯，无论是在我们的室友关系中，还是在家庭成员之间、同事之间、朋友之间，通常都是由于自我毁灭倾向以及诸如不安全感、对亲密关系的恐惧、未解决的情感问题和控制欲困难等原因造成的，所有这些都是自我破坏的根源。同样，如果你发现自己不断陷入与同类人交往的关系中，
often the repetition of these kinds of behaviors and the repetition of these choices shows that we are not a consciously aware of the decisions we are making but be there is some part of us that knows we are going to be let down knows we are going to be disappointed and allows us to be in that situation another big sign is engaging in negative self-talk talking down to ourselves i think that that is increasingly a massive issue in generation, but also finding that no matter how committed you are to a goal, you cannot follow through. And you know, motivation isn't everything. Sometimes the reason we can't sustain our commitment to our goals is because of this anti-self or unconscious element of our ego, which seeks to sabotage our
通常这些行为的重复和这些选择的重复表明，我们A没有清醒地意识到我们正在做出的决定，B我们内心深处的某个部分知道我们会失望，知道我们会沮丧，并允许自己处于那种境况中。另一个大信号是进行消极的自我对话，对自己说丧气话。我认为这在这一代人中越来越成为一个巨大的问题，而且你会发现，无论你对一个目标有多么坚定，你都无法坚持到底。你知道，动力并不是全部。有时我们无法坚持实现目标的原因是因为这个反我或我们自我的无意识元素，它试图破坏我们的
logical goal-orientated behavior. It is the easiest thing in the world to give up, especially when we subconsciously don't believe that we deserve what we're after. And it's not always your fault. You know, no one wants to deliberately fail on a conscious level, but it is these factors such as a fear of failure, a fear of success, and unconscious behaviors that contribute to this output and contribute to this pattern. It all comes back to self-sabotage. Obviously, this is just a very high-level list.
符合逻辑的、以目标为导向的行为。放弃是世界上最简单的事情，尤其是当我们潜意识里不相信自己配得上所追求的东西时。这并不总是你的错。你知道，没有人愿意在意识层面故意失败，但诸如对失败的恐惧、对成功的恐惧以及导致这种产出和这种模式的无意识行为等因素，都是造成这一结果的原因。这一切都归结为自我破坏。显然，这只是一个非常宏观的列表。
we could take this down to such a granular level, depending on the nature of your self-destructive behaviour. But I think that last point really brings us to what I really see is most valuable in this episode, and the most valuable information this episode contains, which is, why do we do this? Why exactly do we self-sabotage? It's such a complicated and nuanced psychological explanation. But I think that if we don't understand the reasoning and the origins and the causes, there is no way that we can address the habit.
我们可以根据你的自我毁灭行为的性质，将其细化到非常具体的层面。但我认为最后一点确实把我们带到了我真正认为本期节目中最有价值的部分，也是本期节目包含的最有价值的信息，那就是，我们为什么要这样做？我们到底为什么要自我破坏？这是一个非常复杂且微妙的心理学解释。但我认为，如果我们不理解其中的推理、根源和原因，我们就无法解决这个习惯。
So I'm so excited to get into that right after this break. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental. toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that
所以我非常高兴能在稍事休息后深入探讨这一点！2%。有扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人数比例是百分之二。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析科学的精神。坚韧、体能以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立心理韧性。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，以超越主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的相信
seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side, a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do a Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at a podcast. I'm Sam Jette.
种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们弄错了。我们在世界上恐慌的许多问题都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在经历之后成为一个更快乐、更满足、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即Apple Podcasts、iHeartRadio应用或您获取播客的任何地方的“2%”。你还记得戴安娜·罗斯在VMA颁奖典礼上双击小金的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什和小金到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《Look Back at it》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·杰特。
I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now.
我是亚历克斯·英格利什。每集节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过那段岁月的。包括最近一期与马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）合作的节目，畅谈80年代的霹雳可卡因。需要说明的是，1984年对我来说意义重大，不仅仅是因为霹雳可卡因。我随时都可以聊聊当天的霹雳可卡因，只是想让大家知道。我的意思是，马克，这是我们讨论霹雳可卡因的第二集了。所以我开始看出这里有一条贯穿始终的线索。我们现在也把艾滋病摆在桌面上。
Thank you finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark, sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing.
谢谢你把那句话说完。是的。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。在iHeartRadio应用、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听Look Back at It。欢迎收听我的新播客《以防万一》，我是你的主持人，也是你最喜欢的治疗师凯尔·盖恩斯。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我带来了我自己在心理健康领域十多年的经验，并与许多令人难以置信的嘉宾进行了对话。我说的是特里普·方丹、瑞安·克拉克，有时当我们追求某样东西时，我们太专注于追逐，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了它。
And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth. Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely.
我们还在追逐。而且我们不知道什么时候才算够了。因为人们会看记分牌。生活变成了一场关于输赢的比赛。史蒂夫·布恩斯、达斯汀·罗斯，因为你觉得在人间时做一个好人很重要。你是个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为那是两种不同的意图，兄弟。绝对的。
And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now.
那是两个不同信任层面的东西。我希望你真的能做一个好人。加入我和凯尔·盖恩斯的行列，在我的新播客《以防万一》中，就治愈、成长、父亲身份、压力和目标进行真正的对话。打开你免费的iHeartRadio应用。搜索“Learn the Hardway”并立即收听。
In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle, to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct?
2023年，前钻石单身汉明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己处于亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。随后的家事法院听证会揭示了她故事中前后矛盾的明显漏洞。这开启了一场长达数年的法庭之争，以证明真相。欧文斯女士，你伪造了这份特定的测试两次，对吗？
I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Lespian and Michael Naroncini. My mind was blown.
我伪造了一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来破解这个案子。我希望人们能够看到他们的税款被用在了什么地方。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们将揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格·莱斯皮安和迈克尔·纳隆奇尼。我的脑子炸裂了。
I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Undermining our own success and our future is a habit we need to break early in our 20s.
我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《爱情陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县传来突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控犯有欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州，正义得到伸张之前，这一切都不会结束。在iHeartRadio应用、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听Love Trapped播客。破坏我们自己的成功和未来是我们必须在二十岁出头时打破的习惯。
are a great time for that. But I think the first step to conquering these tendencies is to understand the origins of self-sabotage. You know, if you don't know the cause of a problem, you cannot treat it. It's like any disease. You can't just treat people for everything, hoping you will address the main problem, and the same can be said for self-destructive behaviours. So I want to discuss some of the various psychological explanations that are rooted in the underlying emotional, cognitive and behavioral processes that create these habits. Obviously, individual experiences will all vary, but I would say that these reasons are the most common. We can't talk about self-destructive behaviours without talking about our childhood. What we witness and experience as children has an
这是个好时机。但我认为克服这些倾向的第一步是了解自我破坏的根源。你知道，如果你不知道问题的根源，你就无法治疗它。这就像任何疾病一样。你不能只是给人们治疗各种疾病，指望能解决主要问题，自我毁灭行为也是如此。所以我想讨论一些各种心理解释，这些解释植根于产生这些习惯的潜在情感、认知和行为过程中。显然，个人的经历各不相同，但我可以说这些原因是最常见的。我们不能在不谈论童年的情况下谈论自我毁灭行为。我们作为儿童所目睹和经历的事情有一个
and I would say very core impact on how we behave and what we believe as adults, particularly if we were raised in an environment of abuse or neglect or of chaos wherein our caregivers were inconsistent or didn't meet our primary physical and emotional needs. Back in 1991, this group of researchers, they decided to investigate this correlation and they found that clinical reports suggested that many adults who engage in self-sabotaging had childhood histories of trauma and a disrupted attachment style. They also concluded that childhood trauma from significant abuse to bullying or a divorce or low school performance, childhood illness and emotional neglect, they all contributed to
而且我想说，它对我们成年后的行为和信仰有着核心的影响，特别是如果我们是在虐待、忽视或混乱的环境中长大的，其中我们的照顾者前后不一，或者未能满足我们的基本生理和情感需求。早在1991年，这群研究人员决定调查这种相关性，他们发现临床报告表明，许多参与自我破坏的成年人都有童年创伤史和破坏性的依恋风格。他们还得出结论，从严重的虐待到欺凌、离婚或学校表现不佳、童年疾病和情感忽视等童年创伤，都促成了
the initiation of self-destructive behavior. but the lack of a secure attachment helped maintain it. So if you were bullied as a child and you internalized that you deserved to be rejected and you deserved to be outcast, but then you also didn't have a parent who was willing to stand up for you, the chances of developing self-sabotaging behaviours later on in life is much higher. And there are also some deeper reasons that are due to this. this unresolved emotional issue and this unresolved cause of low self-esteem. Unresolved emotional trauma, it injures our core beliefs and identity.
自我毁灭行为的产生。但缺乏安全型的依恋有助于维持这种行为。因此，如果你在童年时期受到欺凌，并且你内化了自己活该被排斥、活该被抛弃的想法，但同时你也没有一个愿意为你站出来的父母，那么你以后生活中发展出自我破坏行为的几率就会高得多。还有一些更深层次的原因。这种未解决的情感问题和未解决的低自尊根源。未解决的情感创伤，会伤害我们的核心信念和身份认同。
And the reason behind that is because you feel like you are the one to blame and it makes you feel guilt. We can believe that we are responsible for a lot of what we have experienced because no one has never told us differently. and this fosters negative core beliefs such as that I am unlovable, that I don't deserve good things, that I am unworthy. And sadly, we act accordingly in the only way we kind of know how, which is to confirm those beliefs. This also links to low self-esteem in a study conducted in 2005. I think it actually was the same group of researchers, although I might be wrong, but they undertook a longitudinal study, which is a type of research in which they follow the same group of participants for a period of time to study the impact of a single variable. In this case, it was
其背后的原因是因为你觉得自己是该负责的那个人，这让你感到内疚。我们可能会相信自己对所经历的大部分事情负有责任，因为从来没有人告诉过我们有什么不同。这会助长消极的核心信念，例如我是不可爱的，我不配拥有美好的事物，我是无价值的。可悲的是，我们以自己仅知的唯一方式做出相应的行为，那就是去证实那些信念。这与低自尊也有关，在2005年进行的一项研究中。我想这实际上是同一组研究人员，尽管我可能记错了，但他们进行了一项纵向研究，这是一种研究类型，他们跟踪同一组参与者一段时间，以研究单一变量的影响。在这个案例中，研究的是
childhood abuse and neglect. And they studied the impact of that on long-term outcomes. And what they were exploring was the stability of self-esteem over time and its association with childhood experiences. The findings indicated that individuals who experienced childhood abuse or trauma or neglect were more likely to have lower self-esteem. And when we have lower self-esteem, this results in a lack of belief in ourselves and a continuation of a series of self-fulfilling prophecies. We have never experienced what it feels like to feel secure and loved and that peace because we have only ever survived in chaos and uncertainty. And because of our subconscious need for familiarity, we continue to act in a way that sustains that environment and experience
童年虐待和忽视。他们研究了其对长期结果的影响。他们探索的是自尊随时间的稳定性及其与童年经历的关联。研究结果表明，经历过童年虐待、创伤或忽视的个人更有可能拥有较低的自尊。当我们自尊较低时，这会导致缺乏对自己的信心，并延续一系列自我实现的预言。我们从未体验过感到安全、被爱和那种平静是什么感觉，因为我们只在混乱和不确定中生存过。由于我们对熟悉感的潜意识需求，我们继续以维持那种环境和经历的方式行事
resulting in self-sabotage. It's all very, I think, unconscious and it often occurs even without our voluntary recognition. And it also explains why if you have perhaps dated someone who was like really unkind to you or really injured your self-esteem, you have been conditioned and you might learn once again that you are not worthy. And so for your brain to feel comfortable and understanding, it continues to self-sabotage you. And ultimately, all that does is, like I said, set up a self-fulfilling prophecy that matches what these people have continuously told you about yourself. I think it's also important to talk about this in the sense of a coping mechanism. I know we spoke about that before, but we can use some of these behaviours as a crutch. For example, say we don't
从而导致自我破坏。我认为这一切都非常无意识，而且往往甚至在我们自愿认识到之前就发生了。这也解释了为什么如果你曾经和某人约会过，他可能对你很不好，或者严重伤害了你的自尊，你已经被条件反射了，你可能会再次了解到你是不值得的。因此，为了让你的大脑感到舒适和理解，它继续对你进行自我破坏。最终，就像我所说的那样，这一切所做的就是建立一个自我实现的预言，这与这些人不断对你所说的话相吻合。我认为从应对机制的意义上来说，谈论这一点也很重要。我知道我们之前讨论过这一点，但我们可以将其中一些行为用作拐杖。例如，假设我们不
believe in our abilities or we have a fear of failure. Well, you are never going to have to fail or completely trust in your own skills if you never give yourself an opportunity to succeed. So in this way, self-destructive tendencies protect us from feeling uncomfortable or from injuring our self-esteem. Procrastination, I think, is a great example of this. If you never start, if you never try, you can always blame this for your reason for failing, because if you actually tried and you failed, that would hurt so much more. It's a crutch. It's something that you rely on to protect yourself and make yourself feel better. I think about that in the sense of alcohol. as well and the use of social media or keeping yourself really busy to keep yourself distracted from
相信自己的能力，或者我们对失败感到恐惧。那么，如果你从来不给自己成功的机会，你就永远不必经历失败，也永远不必完全信任自己的技能。通过这种方式，自我毁灭的倾向保护我们免受不适感的侵害，或者免受自尊心受损的侵害。我认为拖延就是一个很好的例子。如果你从来不开始，如果你从来不尝试，你总是可以把这作为你失败的原因，因为如果你真的尝试了而失败了，那会痛苦得多。这是一个拐杖。这是你用来保护自己并让自己感觉更好的依靠。我认为酒精也是如此，还有使用社交媒体，或者让自己非常忙碌，以此来转移注意力，不去理会
your problems. I think in this sense though with procrastination and with a lot of these things it kind of all comes down to this dual fear of failure but also fear of success. You know this fear of success involves being afraid of actually meeting your potential being afraid of being afraid of achievement because you don't want to be admired. You don't want to have those responsibilities. You don't want to be in the spotlight and feel like you are going to fail. So you avoid what would be a novel and uncertain situation by unconsciously ensuring that you will never get to the point where you have to be seen as successful, where you do actually put yourself in a place where you are happy because you're afraid of losing that once you achieve it. I think on the other hand,
你的问题。不过我认为在这种意义上，无论是拖延还是很多其他事情，这一切最终都归结为这种对失败的双重恐惧，以及对成功的恐惧。你知道，这种对成功恐惧包括害怕真正发挥自己的潜力，害怕取得成就，因为你不想被仰慕。你不想承担那些责任。你不想成为焦点，觉得你会失败。所以你通过无意识地确保自己永远不会达到必须被视为成功的那一步，来避开这种新奇且不确定的情况，你并没有真正把自己置于一个快乐的地位，因为你害怕一旦实现了它就会失去它。另一方面，我认为
what comes into play here is a fear of failure or even rejection. And what that means is that we may handicap ourselves to the point where we never have to be in a situation where it is even possible for us to succeed. You know, you can begin to see here how complicated this interaction is, but also how every person's individual profile and experiences and history will mean that they act very differently. There have also been some suggestions in psychology that self-sabotage is a form of punishment. And if we look at this,
这里发挥作用的是对失败甚至拒绝的恐惧。这意味着我们可能会自我设限，以至于我们永远不必处于甚至有可能成功的境地。你知道，你在这里开始可以看到这种互动有多么复杂，但同时每个人的个人经历、经历和历史也意味着他们的行为会有很大差异。心理学中也有一些观点认为，自我破坏是一种惩罚形式。如果我们看看这一点，
especially in the context of emotional trauma or low self-esteem and feeling like we are not good enough because of what others have told us, we can see why. Individuals who carry unresolved guilt or shame from past experiences may engage in self-sabotage as a way to punish themselves for their perceived wrongdoings or for the behaviour that they accepted from others. They may believe that they deserve to suffer or they deserve to face negative consequences, leading them to self-sabotage their own efforts or opportunities because they don't really know what it would be like
特别是在情感创伤或低自尊的背景下，因为别人的话而觉得自己不够好，我们就能理解原因了。那些背负着过去经历带来的未解罪恶感或羞耻感的人可能会进行自我破坏，以此来惩罚自己所认为的过错，或者是为了惩罚他们所接受的来自他人的行为。他们可能认为自己理应遭受痛苦，或者理应面对负面后果，这导致他们破坏自己的努力或机会，因为他们真的不知道去挑战这种信念并看看另一面会是什么感觉。
to challenge that belief and see what's on the other side. Thinking back to some of the signs of these behaviours, we spoke a bit about learned helplessness and I think that this is very much an output of that. I want to give one final reason here around why we self-sabotage that I think is most crucial for people in their 20s. Self-sabotage can often stem from an unconscious conflict between what we think we want in our life and what we actually want. So psychodynamic theories such as psychoanalysis, it proposes that self-sabotage may actually arise from an unresolved conflict or unconscious desires that sabotage our own success or our happiness because we actually want something else. We may have been told that we need to desire and want
回想一下这些行为的一些迹象，我们之前讨论过习得性无助，我认为这很大程度上是它的产物。在这里，我想给出最后一个关于我们为什么要进行自我破坏的原因，我认为这对于二十多几岁的人来说最关键。自我破坏往往源于我们自认为在生活中想要的东西与我们实际想要的东西之间的无意识冲突。因此，诸如心理分析之类的心理动力学理论提出，自我破坏实际上可能源于未解决的冲突或无意识的欲望，这些欲望破坏了我们的成功或幸福，因为我们实际上想要别的东西。我们可能被告知我们需要渴望和想要
one thing such as success and admiration and accolades, but actually at our core, we really don't want those things. We want a happy and quiet and peaceful life and because we haven't yet been able to actually recognize that because we are consciously pursuing what we think society wants from us, we silently sabotage our goals in an effort to actually achieve the outcome that we really want. Or when we think about this in the sense of a romantic connection or a relationship, maybe deep down, you know that this person is not right for you. You know that you do not want to be with this person. So subconsciously, you undermine the relationship, you start conflict, you sabotage it in hope that they will leave you and your problem will be resolved. None of this is obviously pleasant
一件事，比如成功、赞誉和荣誉，但实际上在我们的内心深处，我们真的不想要这些东西。我们想要一个快乐、安静和平静的生活，正因为我们还没有能够真正认识到这一点，因为我们正在有意识地追求我们认为社会对我们的期望，我们默默地破坏我们的目标，以便真正实现我们真正想要的结果。或者当我们从浪漫关系的角度来思考这个问题时，也许在内心深处，你知道这个人不适合你。你知道你不想和这个人在一起。所以你在潜意识里破坏这段关系，引发冲突，破坏它，希望他们能离开你，你的问题就能得到解决。这一切显然都不令人愉快，
or desirable or ideal, especially in our 20s when we want to achieve our goals. We want to be happy in our relationships. We want to be making the right decisions and be fulfilled. And as we said before, we want to have agency over our decisions. So how do we stop? How do we break the cycle of being our own worst enemy? I think it starts with self-awareness. And yes, I know that is very broad, but let me explain a bit further. These habits and actions which contradict our conscious goals are very much internal.
也不令人向往或理想，尤其是在我们的二十多几岁时，当我们想要实现目标时。我们希望在关系中感到快乐。我们希望做出正确的决定并获得成就感。正如我们之前所说，我们希望对自己的决定拥有自主权。那么我们该如何停止？我们如何打破成为自己最大敌人的循环？我认为这始于自我觉察。是的，我知道这很宽泛，但请允许我进一步解释。这些与我们有意识的目标相矛盾的习惯和行为很大程度上是内在的，
And they have an unconscious basis, but they also show up very tangibly. So it's about being able to recognize those cues from your environment and from what's happening in your life that the way you are acting is perhaps not efficient or productive. Pay attention to those patterns of self-sabotage and identify the triggers, the thoughts and the emotions that precede these behaviors. I think becoming aware of the underlying reasons behind you, you know, behind why you self-sabotage is the first step in addressing them. So, for example, if you find that you only ever engage in indecisiveness or you distract yourself or you isolate when you are feeling really overwhelmed, it may be because of these unconscious beliefs about your capabilities and that maybe you don't deserve good things, you don't
它们有着无意识的基础，但它们也表现得非常切实。所以这关乎能够识别来自环境以及生活中发生的事件的那些线索，即你的行事方式可能并不高效或富有成效。注意这些自我破坏的模式，并识别先于这些行为的触发因素、想法和情绪。我认为意识到你内心深处原因背后的东西，你知道，意识到你为什么会自我破坏，是解决这些问题的第一步。因此，例如，如果你发现自己只有在感到真正不知所措时才会优柔寡断、分散注意力或孤立自己，这可能是因为这些关于你能力的无意识信念，也许你觉得不配拥有美好的事物，你不
deserve to work hard or you don't deserve to properly rest. All of it, I think, comes from beliefs that we have about ourselves and what we deserve. And by addressing those, we addressed the behavior that stems from that. I think also part of that is challenging negative beliefs, examining and challenging those things that you hold about yourself, those ideas that you have about yourself, such as feeling unworthy or fearing success, is really valuable here. want to replace those negative beliefs, which are the origins of self-sabotage, with more positive and realistic ones. And a main way that we do this is through cognitive behavioral therapy, CBT. We talk about this all the time. Essentially, the basis of this method or this
配努力工作，或者你不配好好休息。我认为这一切都源于我们对自己以及我们配得上什么的信念。通过解决这些问题，我们就能解决由此产生的行为。我认为其中一部分还包括挑战负面信念，审视和挑战你对自己的那些固有看法，比如自我贬低或害怕成功的想法，在这里非常有价值。我们希望用更积极、更现实的信念来取代那些作为自我破坏根源的负面信念。我们做到这一点的主要方法是通过认知行为疗法（CBT）。我们一直在讨论这个。本质上，这种方法或这种
practice is by challenging our cognitions, such as I do not deserve happiness, we change our behavior. So it's about looking at what are those thoughts? And challenging them. What is the evidence for our unworthiness? What is the evidence for needing to feel guilty about good things happening? What is the evidence around this idea that we can't be happy? When you look at the evidence for those and you manage them in an objective rather than a subjective manner, you get to change your behavioral outputs. The other thing is to build healthy coping strategies. You want to replace those self-destructive behaviors with healthier ones, engaging in activities that promote self-care, that promote reducing your stress
实践的基础是通过挑战我们的认知，例如“我不配拥有幸福”，从而改变我们的行为。所以这关乎审视这些想法是什么，并挑战它们。我们不配得到的证据是什么？我们需要为发生好事感到内疚的证据是什么？围绕我们不能快乐这一观点的证据是什么？当你寻找这些证据并以客观而非主观的方式管理它们时，你就能改变你的行为产出。另一件事是建立健康的应对机制。你希望用更健康的习惯来取代那些自我毁灭的行为，参与促进自我照顾、促进减轻压力
and improving your emotional well-being, like exercise, like mindfulness, journaling, or engaging in hobbies you enjoy will break the habit of going to what you believe is most convenient, which is the behaviors that actually undermine your success. And I think the final element of this is around accountability. Often, We do not consciously realize when something is a problem, but there are people in our lives who do. So reaching out to your family, your friends, or a therapist even, who can provide support and guidance and accountability is so valuable here. I think you really need people who are going to be honest with you. And like, trust me, tough love is such a blessing sometimes.
和改善情绪健康的活动，比如运动、正念、写日记，或者从事你喜欢的爱好，这将打破走向你认为最方便的习惯，也就是那些实际上会破坏你成功的行为。我认为这最后一个要素是关于问责制。通常情况下，当出现问题时，我们并没有有意识地意识到，但我们生活中的其他人却意识到了。因此，向你的家人、朋友甚至治疗师寻求支持、指导和问责在这里非常有价值。我认为你确实需要那些会对你诚实的人。而且，相信我，严厉的爱有时真是一种福气。
I remember when I was maybe like 19 or 20, I kept dating these like awful people who were all the same. They were like a copy and paste version of each other. And one of my friends was like, Gemma, just in case you don't see it, literally every single one of these men is exactly the same. And you are just putting yourself in the same situation again and again. And it was self-sabotage. I didn't think I deserved real deep love. and I was reinforcing that implicit belief I had about myself by dating people who I knew would never challenge that and who I knew would confirm what I thought was intrinsic and innate about myself.
我记得当我大概19或20岁的时候，我一直和一些糟糕透顶的人约会，他们都一个样。他们就像彼此的复制粘贴版本。我的一个朋友说：“杰玛，以防你看不出来，这些男人中的每一个都一模一样。你只是在一次又一次地把自己置于同样的境地中。”这就是自我破坏。我认为自己不配得到真正深沉的爱，我通过和那些我知道永远不会挑战这一点的、我知道会证实我对自己的内在和天生看法的那些人约会，来不断强化我对自己内隐的信念。
It was a bit of a rude awakening, I will say, but I think we all need people in our lives who aren't afraid to be honest and keep us accountable in a compassionate manner. I think there is a difference between someone being like, oh my God, you always make such stupid decisions. That's just like entirely unhelpful. There's a difference between that and someone being like, hey, I just want to flag this with you that you said that drinking makes you feel uncomfortable and that drinking is taking away from your goals and that you would much rather spend that time focused on yourself or in bed or meditating or doing something non-alcohol related. and I can see that you're not really following that goal that you had for yourself. And I think that's really valuable, having people who love you enough and care about you enough to actually remember what you want from your life and remember your goals and who will tell you
可以说这是一个当头棒喝，但我认为我们生活中都需要这样的人，他们不怕诚实，并以富有同情心的方式让我们承担责任。我认为有人对你说“天哪，你总是做出这么愚蠢的决定”和这之间是有区别的。这完全毫无益处。这与有人对你说“嘿，我只是想向你指出，你说过喝酒让你感到不舒服，喝酒夺走了你的目标，你其实更愿意把时间花在关注自己、躺在床上、冥想或做一些与酒精无关的事情上，我能看出你并没有真正遵循你给自己定的目标”之间是有区别的。我认为这真的很有价值，拥有那些足够爱你、足够关心你的人，他们能真正记住你对生活的期望和你的目标，并会告诉你
when you are perhaps self-sabotaging. So I think those are some of the main strategies that I've adopted and that I think we should all adopt if we come to recognize that our pattern of decisions and our habits are actually not entirely aligned to the lifestyle and the life we want to lead. I will say it one final time. This is entirely normal. Self-sabotage is I think something a lot of us have to come to recognize. I would really encourage you to look at your life and try and identify what behavior. don't really align with your higher self or your long-term goals or the kind of the life that you want or what you want from your emotional well-being or your mental state. Is there something that
什么时候你可能在进行自我破坏。所以我想这些是我已经采用的一些主要策略，如果我们认识到我们的决策模式和习惯实际上并不完全符合我们想要过上的生活方式和生活，我认为我们都应该采用这些策略。我最后再强调一次。这完全是正常的。我认为自我破坏是我们许多人必须认识到的事情。我真的鼓励你审视自己的生活，并尝试找出哪些行为并不真正符合你更高的自我、你的长期目标、你想要的生活，或者你对情绪健康或精神状态的期望。是否有某些事
you are doing perhaps unconsciously that is not helpful? I think when we take time to reflect and to sit with our decisions and think about them consciously, often it's like a Pandora's box. We suddenly reveal so many, like, dark habits and, like, unconscious behaviors that we didn't even realize we were performing as an act of self-sabotage. So I really hope that this has been useful and that you have learned something. I always say this. I know I sound like a broken record, but, like, I really needed to, like, investigate this. I was talking to my friends around self-sabotage and our own lives, and I was like, holy shit, like, there has been a lot of things I've been doing recently, a lot of negative self-talk, a lot of behaviors, a lot of actions that
情你可能是在无意识中做的，而这是没有帮助的？我认为当我们花时间反思并审视我们的决定并有意识地思考它们时，通常就像打开了一个潘多拉魔盒。我们突然发现了那么多黑暗的习惯和无意识的行为，而我们甚至没有意识到自己正在将它们作为自我破坏的行为来进行。所以我真的希望这能对你有所帮助，并且你学到了一些东西。我总是这样说。我知道我听起来像张破唱片，但是，我真的需要好好调查一下这个。我和我的朋友们谈论了我们生活中的自我破坏，我当时想：“天哪，我最近做了很多事情，有很多消极的自我对话，有很多行为，有很多行动，
are actually really contradictory with the life I want to lead. So I really hope that maybe that's something that you are looking out for now as well. Obviously, it's okay to face setbacks. It's okay to, you know, be indecisive and to sometimes have those parts of you that you don't love, but being conscious of them is such a step in the right direction. If there is someone who you think needs to hear this, send it to them, obviously, with compassion like my friend did for me. You never know who it will help out. And if you found this episode helpful, please feel free to leave a five-star review on Apple Podcasts, Spotify, wherever you're listening right now. If you, of course, feel called to do so, it really makes my day, helps the show grow and
其实与我想要过的生活背道而驰。”所以我真的很希望这也是你现在正在关注的事情。当然，面对挫折是可以接受的。优柔寡断，有时拥有那些你并不喜欢的自我部分也是可以接受的，但意识到它们是朝正确方向迈出的重要一步。如果你认为有人需要听到这个，那就把这发送给他们，当然要像我的朋友对我的那样带着同情心。你永远不知道它会帮助到谁。如果你觉得这期节目有帮助，请随时在苹果播客、Spotify或你现在收听的任何地方留下五星好评。如果你当然觉得有必要这样做，这真的会让我的一天变得美好，帮助节目成长并
reach new people. And it's just a small thing I think you can do to, I don't know, maybe make me feel encouraged. Maybe just share on the love, share on some of the positive things in life. And as always, if you have an episode suggestion or if you just want to be in touch, if you want to be part of the community, see what episodes are coming out, see some video clips from these episodes. Please follow me at That Psychology Podcast on Instagram. I'd love to see you over there. Come and say hi. And we will be back next week with another episode. So I will see you then. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter.
接触到新的人。我认为这是你能做的微不足道的小事，我不知道，也许能让我感到鼓舞。也许只是分享爱，分享生活中的一些积极事物。像往常一样，如果你有节目建议，或者只是想保持联系，想成为社区的一部分，看看有哪些节目即将推出，看看这些节目的视频剪辑。请在Instagram上关注我“那个心理学播客”。我很期待在那里见到你。来打个招呼吧。我们下周会带着另一期节目回归。到时见。那是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人数。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。
I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO.% on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. on the Look Back at it podcast For 1979 That was a big moment for me
我是我的播客《百分之二》的主持人。我剖析了在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中培养精神坚韧性、健身和韧性的科学。经历一些艰难困苦，你会以一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的自己重新出现。收听《百分之二》。就在爱心电台应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方。《回顾过去》播客 1979年对我来说是一个重大的时刻
84 was big to me I'm Sam J And I'm Alex English Each episode We pick a year unpack what went down And try to make sense of how we survived it
84年对我很重要 我是山姆·J 和我，亚历克斯·英格利士 每一集 我们挑选一个年份 剖析发生了什么 并试图弄清楚我们是如何度过难关的
With our friends Fellow comedians And favorite authors Like Mark Lamont Hill On the 80s 84 was a wild I mean It was a wild year
与我们的朋友 同行喜剧演员 和最喜欢的作家 比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔 谈论80年代 84年真是疯狂 我的意思是 这是一个疯狂的年份
I don't think There's a more important year for black people Listen to look back at it On the Iheart radio app Apple Podcasts Or wherever you get your podcast Hey, what's good, y'all?
我认为 对于黑人来说没有比这更重要的年份了 收听《回顾过去》 在爱心电台应用、苹果播客 或你获取播客的任何地方 嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？
You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Keer Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax.
你正在收听由你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖姆斯主持的《艰难学习》。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都真的不安全的坦诚对话，但你是在与一个懂行的持证专业人士进行对话。有多少男人穿着一套铠甲。这向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这个能力并不意味着你需要这样做。收听爱心电台应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方上的《艰难学习》。在2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的生父。但这起怀孕似乎是一场骗局。
You doctored this particular test twice in so much. I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped.
你把这个特定的测试篡改了整整两次。我篡改了这个测试一次。这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格·吉莱斯皮和迈克尔·曼奇尼。我的大脑都要炸了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这就是《受困的爱》。
Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面对了后果。在爱心电台应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《受困的爱》播客。这是一个爱心播客。保证是人类制作的。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。